these guys are living every golfer's
dream they're running a par three golf
course and now they're launching a
series of high stakes tournaments where
anyone has the chance to compete it's
called grass league and here's what
makes it different than your average
golf tournament the entire course is set
up for night golf every hole has lights
which makes playing there feel like
you're playing at the World Series or
Monday Night Football for context there
are only 22 night golf courses in the
entire United States also the league
isn't just for pro golfers it's a par
three course so that levels the playing
field literally if you're just a golfer
you could participate in this league and
win big now how much money are we
talking there's 100K in the prize pool
so how did they pull this off it started
with a few friends who were looking for
something more in golf they wanted to
give the average golfer The Full
Experience of competing like a pro with
real Stakes on the line so they
renovated this course in Tempe and put
up lights on every hole on the course in
less than a year the story is so cool
that Bleacher Report decided to partner
with them for the start of grass league
and we'll be working with them to cover
the league and showcase some of the
coolest events and golf stories out
there